auxerre dort encore mais lucile 19 ans
marchent déjà au parc
l'avenir appartient à ceux qui se lèvent
tôt elle le sait et elle le vit depuis
sa rentrée chez les compagnons du devoir
son service débute à 4h à la pâtisserie
roi où elle fera ses classes pendant un
an au labo les débuts se font sur les
chapeaux de roues et ce n'est pas du
gâteau
tous ces 130 grammes l'apprenti n'a
qu'une semaine de pratique à son actif
alors les recettes ne sont pas encore
retenu ni maîtriser un premier dosage
raté pour lui s'il est la crème
pâtissière tourner au vinaigre
[Musique]
en fait descendre et b
le coût de ce nom
mais pas le temps de se morfondre le
deuxième essai sera le bout il y a du
pain sur la planche avant l'arrivée des
clients une cadence à tenir pour suivre
ses co équipiers plus expérimentés et on
enchaîne tarte au sucre adressé
tartelettes à garnir pour remplir la
vitrine est plus compliqué des éclairs à
glacis
j'ai pas envie de décevoir et puis de
retarder si je me loupe par exemple faut
tout recommencer donc ça retarde un peu
de travail coct l'ust il travaille sous
la supervision de pierre edouard le chef
pâtissier de 24 ans a vécu la même
épreuve du feu il y a quelques années
j'ai vraiment fait plus comme ça ça
fasse un tout petit filet voyez top pour
eux ce n'est pas l'état mais non
pourquoi la voleurs prenez c'est surtout
laisser couler en deux fois
quitte même pas c'est même plus doigt la
souris c'est bien
on va essayer de lui montrer vraiment à
100% tout ce qui se passe dans
l'entreprise comment ça se passe et
surtout pas la brusquer pour pas la
dégoûter du métier contre c'est le
risque aussi c'est qu'on a un métier
difficile et le risque de lui donner
envie de partir quoi elle est plutôt
assidus après il ya du travail a failli
arriver je pense qu'avec y arriver elle
a l'air motivé donc ça va très bien
servi
[Musique]
la matinée se termine fini les poupées
et les poches anouilh
c'est l'heure de faire place nette pour
lucile avant de poser le tablier
[Musique]
puis je pense que les gens quand ils
passent de louise se dire oh bah c'est
pas mal ou enfin voila c'est agréable
retour chez les compagnons du devoir
pour le déjeuner autour de lucile
d'autres étudiants avec qui elle partage
son temps libre et les tâches du
quotidien
j'ai bien été accueillies je m'entends
un peu et on nickel c'est comme une
famille avec eux le prévost responsable
du bon fonctionnement de la miss mme
dans dix ans je la vois compagnon
pâtissier du devoir une fois qu'elle
aura réalisé son chef-d'oeuvre son
travail de réception
et puis je pense que je la verrais bien
lui cirais un petit peu timide je pense
que le tour va bien l'aider et je la
vois bien étranger dans dix ans pourquoi
pas avoir ouvert ouvrir sa boutique au
japon ou des choses comme ça je
considère chose qui peut l'intéresser
qu'elle en est capable
dans un an lui s'il pourra décider de
poursuivre sa formation chez les
compagnons et partir faire son tour de
france pourrait prouver sa vocation est
allé au bout de ses ambitions
[Musique]